tweeted a very cute picture of you as a
child
throwbackthursday photo yeah you up
you're just an adorable kid did people
kids you know I should mention I used to
be a train conductor when I was a kid
yeah did you get when you posted that
picture what did you do what did people
say when you put that up cuz it's such
an adorable picture I'm imagining a lot
we're like oh you look at you such a
cute kid well I was really excited cuz I
was I was a cute kid I thought so I
tweeted it and have no first of all I
will say not one compliment not one
positive thing can we see it again yeah
many people thought I just photoshopped
my current face onto some child
conductors bus and nobody one guy said I
rarely has a child been portrayed with
such smugness today you're pretty cocky
yeah I can I have some candy and then a
lot of people people were like I've
never seen a 30 year old baby move so
hard
one guy said this is burned into my
brain
the only aging that happened to you is
that your body grew to match your giant
unchanging head
it's your own fault for putting that out
there yeah I just I honestly had you
know people had made fun of pictures of
me so I was that car let's see what you
do with this okay I regret it hey thanks
for watching please subscribe to my
youtube channel so they will stop making
me shoot these videos please